tres años de turbulento mandato el
presidente colombiano iván duque accedió
al poder siendo un desconocido pero de
la mano del ex mandatario álvaro uribe
vélez cuya sombra la del uribismo
todavía planea sobre la casa de nariño y
ser un país de justicia social en el
campo de justicia social para los
pensionados que pueda ser un país de
propietarios que pueda ser un país de
ciencia tecnología e innovación respeto
por el medio ambiente sus promesas de
justicia social no tardaron en esfumarse
y más bien su mandato ha estado marcado
por grandes desafíos sus bajos índices
de popularidad incluso entre el ala más
radical de su partido el centro
democrático el rebrote de la violencia
debido en parte al rechazo de los
acuerdos de paz de 2016 desde su llegada
a los asesinatos de líderes sociales
aumentaron un 52% según indepaz la
pandemia de coronavirus que sumió al
país andino en una severa crisis
económica y un estallido social que
inició en 2019 en contra de sus
políticas conservadoras un descontento
social que despertó de nuevo el 28 de
abril con su polémica e inequitativa
reforma tributaria que sacó a millones
de personas a las calles durante más de
dos meses en la
mayores movilizaciones sociales de la
historia reciente del país empañadas por
la brutal represión policial que deja
más de 80 muertos y las críticas
internacionales del mandatario entre sus
victorias pese al tropiezo inicial logró
consolidar el plan de vacunación contra
el kobe 19 y el plano internacional la
regularización para cerca de un millón
de migrantes venezolanos indocumentados
hacemos pública la decisión de nuestro
país
de crear un estatuto de protección
temporal en colombia
que nos permita hacer un proceso de
regularización
de esos migrantes que están en nuestro
país con su mandato a punto de culminar
y en medio de una crisis de descontento
social sin precedentes
muchos analistas apuntan que los
comicios presidenciales de mayo de 2022
serían el fin del uribismo